The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So we have x is
going to be whatever number
the user types in, y is
the user types in.
First thing I'm going to
check is if x is equal to y.
So if we type in x is 0 and
y is 5, 0 is not equal to 5,
so we're not even
going to consider
what's in this code block.
Then we're going to check
the next one-- if 0 is
less than 5-- and that's true.
So this is the very
first conditional
that evaluates to
true, so we're just
going to print x is smaller.
And I think that's what's
being dragged down here.
Awesome.